the Joe Rogan experience like Dean went
out and drove a bunch of fast cars out
in Vegas and he was just like deep post
him to he goes I was shown how [ __ ]
cool was and it's like the next time let
that time I went out there I took my
lovely wife with me so we were doing you
know couples [ __ ] I was gonna be like
hey thanks for coming to Vegas someone
go drive some fast cars they have a CVS
that's all lit up the Vegas style you
should check that out howdy you know
like where the [ __ ] would that get me
but uh that was a good trip for us too
by the way a good family Vegas trip yeah
yeah it's a good thing to do as a
married person to just sort of like my
mother-in-law watched our kid and we
came out there and it's fun it's
hilarious that's nice like there yes and
we know but we immediately go right back
to like me my wife have like ridiculous
chemistry laughs and like just totally
on the same wavelength and it just
[ __ ] resets and I'm learning now like
you got it just with the day-to-day in
DeLand you know but you guys do date
nights do you do a lot of date nights
yeah probably not enough it's like
everything do you work out yeah not
enough to eat well yeah not enough and
then your relationship becomes like the
same way and I've I finally gotten out
of my stupid [ __ ] you know died on
every he'll [ __ ] argue everything you
know I'm getting out of that and I'm
starting to understand you know how to
how to do it do you not in competition
with your wife that's what you got to
understand yeah yeah but then there's
also that she's also human so everything
she says isn't right
you just have to pick yeah you got a
pick because I'm not gonna be that guy
where's your happy wife happy life all
those guys are get done I watch whatever
TV she wants to watch I'm envious of
them are you those because they have the
smoothest [ __ ] life never lose their
house they're just like this they like a
[ __ ] you know as big doorman
buildings where I got a package for you
mister like you become that in the
relationship you should just say we're
like the Bell cap and something like
that those Lyford or yeah yeah they're
like in a union neutered yeah
not saying there's anything wrong with
being a doorman before everybody in a
[ __ ] uniform gives me [ __ ] yeah they
like you become like that in the thing
but no we came back and last night you
know before we went to bed my wife was
like glowing she was like I had the best
time and we barely did anything we just
[ __ ] hung out laughing you know
appreciate that a lot more when kids
because you realize like this is a rare
moment this is hard to do it's hard to
get away yeah I mean yeah it's hard to
connect while someone's going I wanna go
I wanna read parsec
[Applause]